bristling with air and sea defenses HMS
Duncan is the latest British warship on
the way to the Gulf seen here sailing
through the Bosphorus with no sign of
tensions easing the UK government is
taking no chances this is a time for
cool heads I'm being briefed on an
hourly basis as to what is going on and
we want to do everything we can to make
sure that we don't have an unintended
escalation which could be very dangerous
for the world but on the other side of
the Atlantic President Trump wasn't
being quite so circumspect Iran better
be careful but they're treading on very
dangerous territory Iran of you're
listening you better be careful
Iran is warning the UK must hand back
its oil tanker the grace one or else
Gibraltar and British forces seized it
accusing Iran of trying to bust EU
sanctions on Syria Iran says the UK is
just doing the bidding of America batsh
aghanim was a hick English this is a
very childish and ridiculous excuse by
the British they should officially
announce that they are servants of
America and act on behalf of America
America has returned their favor wealth
by insulting their ambassador and their
Prime Minister in what was a grave
escalation frigate HMS Montrose was
forced to intervene this week as Iranian
vessels tried to intercept a British
tanker increasing the urgency of
international efforts to protect
shipping in the Gulf
Britain's already part of combined
maritime forces a coalition of 33
nation's leading on security in the Gulf
the Royal Navy already has a total of
six vessels in the region one frigate
for mine hunters and a Royal Fleet
Auxiliary support vessel based in
Bahrain the destroyer HMS Duncan joins
them in a few days a multinational
military coalition is proposed
increasing protection and surveillance
for commercial shipping in the seas off
both Iran and Yemen
the US would provide command ships with
allies like Britain and from
patrolling and escorting vessels
traveling unto their nations flags the
fairies have returned to this the so
called tanker war of the 80s where US
and Iranian forces traded blows and oil
tankers came under regular fire one
voice close to the Iranian government
warned this time could be even worse the
situation in the region is very
different from the 1980s Iran is much
more powerful Iran's capabilities are
incomparable - back then everyone would
lose under such circumstances so I think
that the belief here is that there are
enough saying people in Washington who
would not want to see that happen
whatever same people on either side want
there's also the law of unintended
consequences the risk of
misunderstanding or miscalculation
leading to Swift escalation and
something far more serious Dominik
Waghorn Sky News